we see in a triangle or i guess we know
in a triangle there's three angles and
if we're talking about a right triangle
like the one that i've drawn here one of
them is going to be a right angle and so
we have two other angles to deal with
and what i want to explore in this video
is the relationship between the sine of
one of these angles and the cosine of
the other the cosine of one of these
angles and the sine of the other
so to do that let's just say that this
angle i guess we could call it angle a
let's say it's equal to theta
if this is equal to theta
if its measure is equal to theta degrees
say what is the measure of angle b going
to be
well the thing that will jump out at you
and we've looked at this in other
problems is the sum of the angles of a
triangle are going to be 180 degrees and
this one right over here it's a right
triangle so this right angle takes up 90
of those 180 degrees so you have 90
degrees left so these two are going to
have to add up to 90 degrees this one
and this one angle a and angle b are
going to be complements of each other
they're going to be complementary or
another way of thinking about it is b
could be written as 90
minus theta if you add theta to 90 minus
theta you're going to get you're going
to get or theta to 90 degrees minus
theta you're going to get 90 degrees now
why is this interesting
well let's think about let's think about
what the sign
let's think about what the sine of theta
is equal to
sine is opposite over hypotenuse the
opposite side
is bc
so this is going to be the length of bc
over the hypotenuse the hypotenuse is
side a b
so the length of bc over the length of a
b
over the length of a b
now what is that ratio if we were to
look at this angle right over here well
for angle b bc is the adjacent side and
a b is a hypotenuse for from angle b's
perspective this is the adjacent over
the hypotenuse now what trig ratio is
adjacent over hypotenuse well that's
cosine so katoa let me write that down
sine doesn't hurt sine is opposite over
hypotenuse we see that right over there
cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse k and
toa tangent is opposite over adjacent so
from this angle's perspective taking the
length of bc which is bc is its adjacent
side and the hypotenuse is still a b
so from this angle's perspective this is
adjacent over hypotenuse or another way
of thinking about it's the cosine of
this angle
so that's going to be equal to
the cosine
cosine
of 90 degrees
minus
minus theta that's a pretty neat
relationship the sine of an angle is
equal to the cosine of its complement so
one way to think about it
the sine of we could just pick any
arbitrary angle let's say the sine of 60
degrees
is going to be equal to the cosine of
what and i encourage you to pause the
video and think about it
what's going to be the cosine of 90
minus 60 is going to be the cosine of 30
degrees 30 plus 60 is 90. and of course
you could go the other way around we
could think about the cosine of theta
the cosine of theta is going to be equal
to
the adjacent side to theta to this to
angle a i should say and so the adjacent
side is right over here that's ac
so it's going to be ac
over the hypotenuse adjacent over
hypotenuse the hypotenuse is a b
but what is this ratio from angle b's
point of view well the sine of angle b
the sine of angle b is going to be its
opposite side ac ac over the hypotenuse
a b so this right over here from angle
b's perspective this is angle b's sine
so this is equal to this is equal to the
sine
of
90
minus 90 degrees
minus theta so the cosine of an angle is
equal to the sine of its complement the
sine of an angle is equal to the cosine
of its complement